It was about 10 years into my teaching career
that I was thinking critically about: What
is it that my students are doing and were
they in fact doing science?
And the reality is that they weren’t.
They were doing canned labs where they were
generating data that was predictable and they
weren’t really having that opportunity to
fail at anything and then have to do any error
analysis whatsoever.
And that’s just not how science works.
So over the past decade in particular I worked
with other teachers here and we started to
look out for broader scientific opportunities.
And one of those opportunities we brought
in was this Wolbachia project which involves
a lot of technical skill and a lot of pieces
and a lot of prep work.
It’s five days of lab and at the end of
that five days of lab it’s not guaranteed
that you’re going to get data.
It’s the antithesis of the labs that we
did before, which we made sure we could fit
in a 47-minute period and we’d get known
results at the end.
This is the exact opposite.